A moment of pure terror.
People fleeing for their lives in Malatya, Turkey.
Whole buildings reduced to dust as the powerful earthquake ravaged Turkey and Syria.
Rescuers now battling freezing temperatures as they sift through debris,...
...searching for survivors and pulling out the dead.
Many left waiting in shock for news of family and friends.
Turkey's President Erdogan called it the worst disaster since the 1930s.
We do not know how far the number of dead and injured will rise...
...as debris removal works continue in many buildings in the quake zone.
Our hope is that we will recover from this disaster with the least loss of life.
One woman trapped in her destroyed apartment building rescued by crane.
Cheaply and improperly built apartments have been a problem across the country,...
...many of them now teetering on the edge of collapse.
Across the border in Syria,...
...workers scrambled to pull victims out from under destroyed buildings.
A harrowing scene of a baby born in the rubble...
...who was rushed to safety.
The mother did not survive.